well i want to congratulate you for
beating your charge on my mama congrats
on that
mama
the last time you were here um
i was like it was still in the air like
what was going on you couldn't really
talk about it too much but now it's now
that you're on the other side of it yeah
i know how stressful that is like
waiting to see what happens with a
charger that should be [ __ ] up bro
that should be [ __ ] up for real for
real but you know i got a good faith i
got good faith though shout out to your
lawyer too yeah i had a good air lord
shout out to you
yeah
it really wouldn't work man i thought it
was oh man shut up
yeah it sounded like it was over with
because i just saw you
and then that [ __ ] happened and i was
like god damn it so like what is
happening
and then you had gotten shot at like you
know the year before i'm like dude can
someone get put this guy in the house
and just just
please not let him out i be chilling
though huh people be painting a
different picture of me man i'm a cool
[ __ ] man you know i'll be
chilling
um
talk about this new album man is it a
mixtape is it album what is it it's a
project whatever that means
body of work yeah it's battle where it
goes out of your work yeah i named him
this guy doka i feel like i'm one of
many kids who was misguided growing up
watching the wrong things and [ __ ] you
know
paying attention to the wrong people and
they were they mistakenly showing me
this [ __ ] they ain't even doing it on
perfect they ain't even misguided me
it's part of your environment exactly
so i'm just not learning this [ __ ]
like positive [ __ ] that i can do
different and [ __ ] no i'm saying so i
wanna i want to be the one that changed
the upcoming [ __ ] trying to say
um
what point in time did you feel like you
were finally starting to kind of
grasp like
the life [ __ ] because it's hard to
really like you know i'm just not i'm
just
probably like
like the last year and a half obviously
you go through traumatic [ __ ] you almost
lose your life and you almost lose your
life to a charge exactly yeah so they
like the leg
the legs like you in the head did i just
sit down on the ankle on the ship
it really wasn't like an eye opening
[ __ ] by life for me you know what i'm
saying yeah
do you feel like uh are you moving
different
yeah yeah that's a kid and [ __ ] you know
yeah that's new yeah he doesn't know
yeah that's a kid that's it security is
important man yeah that's a very
important forever it's a very imp i feel
like if you're a certain
stature in the game like
it's almost necessary man
it's not like no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm
moving around with no security like
you're an idiot
you're a [ __ ] idiot because you mean
a lot to a lot of people exactly and hey
if you gone it's [ __ ] everything's gone
for real then what happens so we were
talking a little bit uh
obviously we saw
kevin laws went to bat for yso uh you're
obviously under 300 and you said that
you really loved the way that they had
your back during the whole process you
know a lot kevin loves real [ __ ] no
ain't gonna like the whole 300 for real
for real like they they baked the [ __ ]
the whole time supporting the [ __ ]
family like even when it's [ __ ] first
like that one of my first thoughts like
damn bro like [ __ ] i know that ain't
gonna [ __ ] with me right
very high profile video shoot too it
wasn't like this
you know
like even if i ain't do [ __ ] like yeah i
know it look bad you know
so i'm like man that ain't gonna [ __ ]
with me bro but hey they stood on this
[ __ ] though like yeah [ __ ] that that's
amazing you know what it is too it's
like you we always hear it guilty and
too proven innocent but the problem is
is that the public don't think that way
yeah man the public sees a headline and
they already got their mind made up so
now it's on you
and then they'll sw then they'll make
their own store with the headline like
[ __ ] dude what happened like no i'm
saying [ __ ] come to me and ask
me like oh so this is this is what
really happened to [ __ ] like that like
no i don't know the [ __ ] out
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i
ain't got no beef no rappers and [ __ ]
man